it's the last night of the notting hill
carnival
and the mood has just turned
just minutes ago this was a celebration
of culture
but it's now a crime scene
a young man who traveled from bristol
with his younger sister has been stabbed
takeo nemad a rapper known as tk was
taken to hospital but didn't make it
in the days after i spent some time with
his inner circle of family and friends
as they come to terms with this brutal
murder
[Music]
this is tk's producer and manager chris
patrick he worked with tk for the last
two years i've come to see him 48 hours
after the killing we got the phone call
and
at first
i i thought that maybe it's just a
scrape so
that that's that's the initial response
and then obviously we heard that it was
maybe a little bit more serious um
and you know we made
we made our way to the hospital to you
know obviously
very bad news devastating news
[Music]
tk was an up-and-coming artist well
known in bristol
his music has hundreds of thousands of
views on social media
but he came to chris two years ago
because he wanted to break through
nationally
he came here with a family
that was firmly in his corner
his dad his mum his sisters
firmly in his corner you don't
ordinarily get that
and especially not when it comes to rap
music or drill music or whatever the
names that people need
[Music]
drill music which tk specialized in has
been criticized for glorifying violence
[Music]
drill gets bad headlines right yeah i
mean he's clearly a talented kid right
but just looking at some of his lyrics
you know when he sometimes talks about
kind of chinging and clicking which is
obviously kind of stabbing and shooting
okay
do you worry that
that could have a negative influence
well
no
and i i think a lot of people have tried
to
um
explain what drill is about what i began
to understand about drill music
is that it's a form of expression most
of these guys that are doing the drill
drill music or even just rap music i
don't want to call it drilling in
vertical it's rap music in the end most
of them that are doing it they want a
way out but they also just want to be
heard tk wanted to be heard my man got
touched a subject now the first one mate
man the suspect tko up next
[Music]
left behind his girlfriend and their
unborn son
the day after his death she posted this
picture and wrote so grateful to be
carrying a part of you
this year's nottingham carnival was the
first in three years because of covid
two million people came to celebrate the
caribbean culture
but on the final day violence crept in
tk's was the first murder of the
festival in 18 years
it was a grim end to a largely
successful event
the organizers want to remind people of
that
you know it's hugely tragic and i don't
ever want to dismiss you know the life
that has been lost he's going he was
going to be a father you know there's a
huge tragedy you know but this this we
are not a monolith
you know we are many things and you know
what happened to him happened after the
masqueraders are pretty much done as
well this is not a reflection of who we
are actually what happened to him is the
opposite of who we are
it's four days on from the murder
tk's blood stains remain on the pavement
where he was attacked
his family are traveling to london
because they need to formally identify
their son's body
how are you doing i join them as they
visit the scene of his killing for the
first time
i'm so sorry
about your son
and could you just tell us a bit about
him
well he was a normal good kid
yeah just came to carnival to enjoy
himself with um with his sister
the sister i just take out the car about
to have fun
then what happened his life was just
taken away
i can't imagine what it's been like you
for the family
well as
with any family who lost a child like
that it's gonna be devastated so it's
hard you know i mean it's hard to carry
on because he's our son and we love him
really he loves us he's got good heart
clean-hearted kid and i mean
just want to do good
that's about it
could you tell me um the moment that you
got the phone call that you realized he
was in some trouble well i was
devastated
i was devastated i was just praying that
he was okay but everything was gonna be
fine
but obviously
work that
and um did you go to the hospital i did
yeah i did
what would you say to any kids who are
thinking about picking up a knife
well i would say
that's the wrong thing to do yeah
you are not going around and trying to
hurt other people you need to show love
love is the answer love is the key if
everybody should love then no one will
hurt each other you hurt each other
so that's all we need to do to show love
and once you have love then you won't be
carrying nothing
his plea for peace comes during the
worst surge of violence in england since
last year
which was the worst on record
in the last 12 months knife crime in the
capital has gone up by more than 10
percent
and it's accelerated even more in the
last month
more than a week after tk's murder
there's still been no arrests
i've come to meet a murder detective
who's just retired from the met
i asked him what clues investigators
will be looking for
in this particular case you have
somebody who's involved in drill music
and rap music and
and there is always that
element where drill music has that
unfortunate
notability for being something where
violence and serious violence and murder
and possession of guns and knives has
been glorified really
and and so that the music will be looked
into as well and the lyrics you know
it's quite common that
that is a theme that you look at when
you have a victim or a suspect in in a
case like this that there may be clues
within that that drill music in the
lyrics and that's been used in many
court cases in the last really 10 years
knife crime and knife killings this is
something that we talk about every
single year it's not going away why is
it not going away and what can the
police do to try and uh combat this
issue and the amount of work that people
are trying to do to stop this
and and but why isn't it stopping are
the sentences the equivalent of carrying
a knife are they not proportionate
enough
in 30 years of policing the amount of
stabbings that i went to
you know really i
i couldn't remember them all there's
just so many and how many ended up in in
fatalities again
if i sat down for a couple days and
recounted them it's just a ridiculous
number and this is just another
another one you know and it can't be it
can't be counted like another one
it's upsetting but your love is carrying
us through so we really appreciate it
and we just want to set off these smoke
bombs like what he had in the video the
green ones his favorite color yeah yeah
it's caribbean tradition to hold a
celebration of life on the ninth night
after someone's death
tk's family and friends gather at the
family home to celebrate his life and
remember him
show love from your heart
to everyone
and we will be all living
peace you